mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues la question s'adresse à
madame la ministre des solidarités de la
santé madame la ministre
la difficulté d'accès aux soins
deviennent source d'inquiétude pour une
partie grandissante de la population
surtout rurales et périurbaines dans
certaines spécialités
il est coupé d'attendre six mois pour
avoir un rendez vous certes la médecine
est quasiment gratuite car prise en
charge par la sécurité sociale et par
les complémentaires santé
mais la question de la santé dans les
territoires se pose maintenant en termes
d'équité
il ya désormais profondes injustices
dans l'accès aux soins et cela est vrai
pour la médecine de ville comme pour
l'hôpital les pouvoirs publics et vous
n'avez pas fait exception à la règle
on a cumulé les plans contre les déserts
médicaux
mais des plans sans efficacité car il ne
traite pas les causes du mal on y
retrouve des incitations financières est
d'ailleurs souvent à la charge des
communes mais on y trouve surtout la
bureaucratisation et la
fonctionnarisation rampante de la
médecine à ceux qui s'alarmait d'une
situation devenue intenable
vous avez répondu suppression du numerus
clausus c'est-à-dire suppression de la
limitation du nombre de médecins formés
cette suppression était présentée comme
la solution aux problèmes mais dans les
fêtes les facultés de médecine
soucieuse de la qualité des formations
ont d'ores et déjà annoncé qu'elle
n'avait pas les moyens d'augmenter le
nombre d'étudiants en médecine
madame la ministre l'avenir de médecine
et suscite une vision stratégique les
déserts médicaux ne sont que le symptôme
du déclin d'autres médecine de santé
la crise est donc très simple être prêt
à abandonner les fausses solutions qui
ne cessait de dégrader la situation
êtes vous prête à réformer vraiment en
repensant l'actuelle gouvernance
asphyxiante de la santé en france
en démontrant votre confiance dans
l'exercice libéral de la médecine parce
après valorisation